[Musique]
ils en pensent quoi ton frère c'est
simple voilà quand on pose des questions
aux gens pendant qu'ils nous répondent
on part très très vite se déguiser dans
un camion et on revient à billets comme
eux peu près c'est pas avatar non plus
un regarde est ce que vous pensez
transports en commun parisiens
je pense que c'est un gros bazar très
très gros bazar les gens sont en ce sens
très mal là un manque d'organisation
total pas surtout c'est tout propre
n'avons pas quoi et c'est très cher pour
ce que c'est je vote frais ils en
pensent quoi mes frères bats mon frère
il est alors aisé qui gère des centres
de formation de merde je trouve que le
métro français était exceptionnelle et
votre frère ils en pensent quoi à mon
frère lui il n'est pas du tout
incarne une caméra cachée andry mal
cachée je vous passe tout en taxi en
fait et votre elle en pense quoi
mon frère frère mon frère cheikh pas
loger caste
j'aime la vie tu en penses en concert
demain soir elle tony garnier
j'ai bien ciao qu'est ce que vous pensez
des transports en commun parisiens le
bus c'est super et je trouve qu'en fait
les marchandises devraient transiter par
le tout donc par les métros et que les
gens doivent
être en plein air pour regarder la
beauté de paris votre charles pasqua ma
soeur elle est à new york là je suis
revenu j'ai pas autant déborder on
n'arrête pas passé mais en sont d'accord
on se dit qu'ils n'ont pas aimé c'est
new york ça m'a rendu un peu con cannes
comme i sava les perturbations sur les
lignes de temps en temps les gens
pensent que c'est inévitable
donc j'ai prévu si les incidences sur
les lits et quand je prends le bus je
peux savoir à quelle heure elle proche à
lu il votre frère il en pense quoi
mon frère j'ai pas de frère commandait
pas non
bon c'est pas le but
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens il me conviennent le
métro quand je veux aller vite
le bus quand j'ai envie de me promener
le rer pour aller vite et votre sol en
pense quoi
j'aime pas de serre bah ouais elle fait
la belle à lattes et pourtant je suis
embêté que le bahut la retourne alors un
registre si on parle du bus
ouais je pense quand même qu'on n'a pas
grand chose à reprocher sauf que
évidemment dans les rues embouteillées
ils sont soumis il ya il devrait y avoir
des morts des allées spécifique des en a
mais il ya souvent aussi des gens qui
stationnent etc mais qui gèle les
transports et peu de salles en pense
quoi
franchement vous croyez vraiment qu'on
connaît gao prince transports en commun
franchement ont tué l'homme ne s'est pas
sûr qu'on cheval j'en reviens c'était
une horreur
là j'ai des choses à dire bon en fait je
suis pas trop les transports en commun
vu que je me déplace en skate alors à
quoi mais je pense que son bien donc
voilà
et qu'est ce qu'il en pense votre bas
j'espère fait demander ça aux les jeunes
ça ride s'arrête là va y joue pas là
tous les loups 24 février puis de la
glisse on sera là
est ce que vous pensez des transports en
commun parisiens
j'en pense que du bien je pense que ça
va très vite c'est très bien et votre
sort penses quoi naceur du bien aussi
on les prend souvent ensemble et c'est
vrai que voilà c'est bon après faut
faire attention parce qu'il ya quand
même des bêtes féroces toi moi j'étais
attaqué parole oui il ya de cela vingt
minutes réussi à m'en faire une petite
laine mais il s'est bien débattu le bon
grain à chaque fois que je viens à paris
j'essaye de les prendre
où je marche à pied quand je peux je
marche à pied quand j'ai pas le temps je
prends le métro
rarement le bus bonjour ça la france un
salut ça hall fait qu'il donne à toi
il paye bien le pack i pad et dimanche
on mangeait pas sa maison
federica qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun parisiens un
mécanisme
ak oui
c'est assez compliqué parce qu'il ya
souvent du monde
votre salaire
ça en soi
de savoir
nous sommes les deux bonasse et sur une
civière du j'ai beau je suis obama ben
c'est super efficace parce qu'il n'y a
pas besoin de prendre de voiture et je
pense que si je vivais à paris et ce qui
n'arrivera pas je n'achèterai pas de
voiture je prendrais juste le transport
en commun et vote charland bon choix
ma soeur baala ces caméras 4 non c'est
une connerie
alors ça l'est tout le monde dans le
futur surtout sur les lignes qui vont
vers la banlieue et il faudrait
humaniser les transports c'est à dire
qu'il devrait y avoir des toilettes dans
les compartiments
j'ai votre char penses quoi ma soeur
n'utilisent pas les transports en commun
nouvel effet de quoi y en a qui doivent
reconnaître
je ne sais pas quelle mère à bouliac
trio ya onze ans à peine ou le petit a
grandi et on sentait que jean michel
ménard ocha a vécu ses intérêts tant
témoin quand je prends les transports en
communs j'observe beaucoup les gens et
je m'ennuie jamais c'est comme un
spectacle en fait tu penses quoi
massa réduit pas à paris
mais se coller laquelle tu préfères
qu'elle soit tu préfères mois puisqu'il
est faux tout en jurant doute choisi
maintenant la housse marocaine battant
satanas à moi maintenant
[Musique]